it's real and it's coming this year
valve announced that Counter-Strike 2
will be released in summer 2023 with
limited testing available to some
Counter-Strike Global Offensive players
starting today but whether you're
eligible or not will depend on a number
of factors including Recent Play Time
and steam account standing players who
have been selected will automatically
get an invite via CS Go's main menu CS2
will be a free upgrade to CS go and all
CS go items will be transferred over
into the new iteration this essentially
sounds like Counter-Strike 2 will
replace csgo something players weren't
sure about when CS2 rumors started to
make their rounds accompanying the
announcement valve also released three
videos teasing what to expect in the
counter-strike's massive and
transformative update made using the
source 2 engine leveling up the world
showed off the upgraded maps and graphic
overhauls moving beyond tick raid
announced the ticker rate will no longer
matter AKA moving and shooting will be
equally responsive and responsive smokes
detailed the new Dynamic volumetric
nature of smoke grenades Community map
makers will also be able to use Source 2
including a source 2 item Workshop
available to try out during the limited
test period don't you just love when
rumors turn out to be true especially if
it's something you were looking forward
to in other online gaming news red foam
might drop its always online requirement
for its single player mode director
Harvey Smith told Eurogamer that
developer Arcane is actively working to
drop the requirement but nothing is
confirmed at this stage Smith said quote
we have to do some things like encrypt
your save games and do a bunch of UI
work to support it I'm not supposed to
promise anything but we're looking into
and working actively toward fixing it in
the future if Arcane does end up
dropping his always online requirement
for single player it remains to be seen
whether or not this would be in place
for launch this may but why Always
online in the first place Smith
explained that it was about capturing
player data to make the game even better
as opposed to anything Insidious however
despite this Smith acknowledged that
some people don't have access to a
constant and stable internet connection
and said critique of the requirement is
legitimate now let's switch gears from a
day one game pass game to a day one
Playstation Plus game you don't hear
that too often meet your maker the PVP
rating and building game has announced a
Cross promo with dead by daylight that
will be available on day one meet your
maker players will get a dead by
daylight deco pack and dead by daylight
players will get a pentacath soup for
Meg Thomas and three unique killer
weapons let me know in the comments if I
butchered the name of that suit the DVD
deco pack contains two building blocks
inspired by the McMillan estate realm
one animated generator prop one pallet
prop one basement light prop and decals
based on dead by daylight so we already
know about me or make sure but hit the
comment section and let me know what
free games you're hoping to see in the
April PlayStation Plus essential tier
I'll see you tomorrow
foreign